es hat in den 13 jahren in dem jetzt
nach medien erkennen gesucht wird jede
menge grabe um gegeben und jede menge
durchsuchung von brunnen von
grundstücken von waldstücken es ist noch
nie etwas gefunden worden nichts
belastbares nichts was jetzt einem
keller etwa was das gleiche würde man
muss sich auch noch vorstellen dass das
einer der größten kriminalfälle der welt
oder eine der meistbeachteten
kriminalfällen jetzt möglicherweise das
fehlende puzzleteil in einem kleingarten
in hannover gefunden wird das ist schon
gigantisch es kann also dass sie jetzt
im keller gefunden kann alles heißen und
nicht aber sie haben immerhin mal etwas
gefunden das hat es bisher nicht gegeben
wie hoch schätzt die chance ein dass aus
diesem auf- und aus dieser durchsuchung
noch mehr erkenntnisse jetzt über diesen
fall und vielleicht auch der aufklärung
dieses falles gewonnen werden können
ziemlich vor sechs wochen gefragt wie
hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit ein
schätze dass der fall maddie mccann
jemals aufgeklärt wird hätte ich gesagt
0 prozent heute ist es ja so dass wir
jeden tag eine neue eine neuentwicklung
haben in dieser lage das heißt alles ist
denkbar
es ist absolut denkbar dass dieser fall
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
aufgeklärt wird
man muss jetzt aber zur einordnung
einmal sagen was da jetzt passiert in
hannover das ist die logische folge dass
öffentlich machen eines verdächtigen
also die ermittler gehen an die
öffentlichkeit und sagen wir haben da
jemanden der könnte es gewesen sein das
ist sein auto dort hat er gelebt das was
eine telefonnummer
daraufhin gehen hinweise ein diese
hinweise müssten der reihe nach
abgearbeitet werden das war letzte woche
oder vorletzte woche in portugal der
fall da hat man den verschiedenen
brunnen geguckt und nichts gefunden weil
natürlich auch viele leerfahrten viele
hinweise die nichts ergeben dabei sind
in diesem falle aber er hat ja
offensichtlich jemand darauf hingewiesen
dass es einen kleinen garten gibt gegen
christian b womöglich bewohnt oder
benutzt hat und das ist in diesem
kleinen garten einen keller gibt der
offenbar verschüttet ist dieser schwung
geht man jetzt nach und wo könnte man
dinge besser verstecken als in einem
verschütteten keller
du warst damals auch in portugal in dem
hotel wo die kleine maddie mccann
entführt wurde
selbst vor ort die spuren jetzt nach
hannover kannst du uns das ganze nochmal
aufdröseln wie das ganze zustande kam
wie wurde damals auch und portugal die
ersten ermittlungen an gegangen welche
durchsuchung wurden dort durchgeführt es
gab in all den jahren bis plötzlich
christian b auf den plan trat niemals
auch neue ansatz einer spur nach
deutschland
es wurde den ersten tagen vereinigen in
portugal gesucht natürlich es wurde vor
allen dingen den stunden nach der tat
nicht sonderlich glücklich gesucht weil
man davon ausgehen dass merkel den weg
gelaufen ist und dann doch wieder
auftaucht in diesen ersten stunden nach
dem verschwinden hat man sehr wertvolle
zeit verloren
sehr wertvolle zeit in der man hätte
spuren nehmen müssen dna-spuren was auch
immer wer dort am fenster wenn im zimmer
war das ist alles verloren gegangen und
daran krankt die ermittlungen in diesem
fall der 13 jahren die ursächliche
ursprüngliche spurenlage ist zerstört
worden
das heißt man hat nichts belastbares auf
das man jetzt zurückgreifen kann
es ist dann sehr lange in portugal
gesucht worden natürlich in praia da luz
natürlich im umland von praia da luz das
sind jede menge vorbelastete
vorbestrafte kinderschänder dazu befragt
und verhört worden die dort in der
region sich aufhielten
christian beeck ist da aus irgendwelchen
gründen durchs raster gefallen und es
ist immer noch nicht ganz klar warum
möglicherweise hat er die algarve
bereits verlassen und dann gab es
irgendwann auch mal eine spur nach
marokko oder hieß es dann sie sind ja
relativ nahe der meerenge nach marokko
das heißt man kann dann mit der fähre
übersetzen
dann gab es spuren die nach spanien
führten überall wo man erkennen gesehen
worden sein soll
merkel hatte eine sehr auffällige ihres
veränderung im auge das heißt jede menge
über die jahre jede menge hinweise gegen
einen wohl jemand ein blondes kind
gesehen haben will dass eine solche
veränderung in der pupille hat die
finden dann sogar bis nach england ist
in england grundstück durchsucht worden
aber gefunden hat man bei aldi zu suchen
in all diesen jahren mit all diesen
ländern nichts